hallo leute am sonntag haben wir ein
neues video veröffentlicht zum thema wie
alt bist du
und am ende dieses videos haben wir euch
gebeten zu raten wie alt janisch ist
daraufhin sind hunderte vorschläge
eingegangen und die werde ich jetzt
zusammen mechanisch besprechen janesch
bist du bereit für eine zwischenfrage
gibt es was zu gewinnen also der
gewinner der bekommt eine gratulation
von dir
es sind okay es geht los
hanisch ist eigentlich ein perfektes
beispiel dafür wie man immer jung sein
kann nicht in berlin in berlin gibt es
ganz viele von dieser sorte also ältere
leute denen du anziehst dass sie das
geistig jung und ehrlich bleiben ja und
lustig beschreibt körperlich 45 aber
geistig 19
was 45 deine mutter alter 35 hanisch ist
naja das ja nicht janisch ist 46 jahre
alt sagt mit vielleicht körperlich
janisch ist 55 und super cool
danke jannis 53 jahre alt und sieht aus
wie eine glückliche version meiner
physik und chemielehrer in der ersten
klasse der highschool liebe grüße an
diesen leder
ja sagt er ist definitiv 52 war
definitiv älter hanisch ist 45 jahre
älter daniel schreibt iranische 70 jahre
alt wow ziemlich präzise ja besonders
montags jänner sagt janisch assist 52
leukämie 52 das ist ein schönes alter
aber ich bin älter ich würde sagen 60
falsch er ist 62 falsch er ist 65
unverschämt er ist falsch hanisch ist 20
deutsche jahre alt und 53 polnische war
das ist interessant weil ich nämlich
auch so zähle ich bin 54 polnisch und 35
deutsch janisch ist unsterblich sind wir
alle
konzentrier dich ich will nach hause
so jetzt wird's interessant jetzt kommen
nämlich die leute die recherchiert haben
es gab ja auch einige die haben die
mittel der modernen technik genutzt und
haben sich bemüht das echte alter
herauszufinden
50 cm satin video maybe you turn fifty
eight tasche du hast dir eine
gratulation von jannis verdient
herzlichen glückwunsch ganz persönlich
von mir jemand mit einem koreanischen
namen schreibt 3 bibiana ich denke
jannis 59 wie meine mutter schreit
marilyn den montreal
herzlichen glückwunsch an dich und
gleichzeitig an deine mama du wirst
nämlich in zwei tagen
ich werde in zwei tagen 59 also wenn
dieses video rauskommt nur noch ein tag
der unter nacht gehöre ich ganz viele
gratulationen von euch und danach hast
du einfach auf zu wachsen
danach höre ich auf älter zu werden
definitiv sagen jetzt konnte ich ja mal
jemand mit dem namen m bwl 06 auf der
website von easy german habe ich gelesen
dass sie haben es 1984 nach deutschland
eingewandert ist darüber hinaus hat die
haben schon einem interview von easy
polnisch gesagt dass er in deutschland
angekommen ist als der 24 jahre alt war
das heißt er ist im jahr 1960 geboren
statistisch kann man davon ausgehen dass
es nicht im ersten quartal dass er nicht
im ersten quartal des jahres geboren
wird deswegen des jahres im moment 58
jahre
alt aber er wird in diesem jahr 59 sein
bravo herzlichen glückwunsch und
herzliche gratulation von mir persönlich
du hast das rätsel geknackt und zwar mit
sachverstand und recherche jahr ist die
wichtigste frage wie alt fühlst du dich
ich fühle mich noch zwei jahre zwei tage
58 und dann bin ich 59 und ich fühle
mich dann auch verdammt noch mal 59
warum auch nicht
es ist ein sehr schönes alter besonders
wenn man an ein eingehender youtuber ist
dann hat man nichts zu befürchten
dann ist es ein alles völlig egal das
stimmt ich finde das einmal witzig weil
das die einzigen male dass die ich merke
dass du älter wirst als ich oder dass du
schon 59 bis ist wenn wir manchmal
andere 59-jährige treffen
ja die sind christen zum geschrumpft und
alt und völlig reden und deutlich und es
ist durch schlimm ist es nicht
und wann hast du dich in deinem leben am
jüngsten gefühlt ich glaube tatsächlich
als ich nach deutschland kam
als der stress weg war und dann ist das
erste jahr war das war eine wie ferien
wie ein jahr verging in einer
zauberhaften neuen welt und es gab keine
verpflichtungen und jeden tag bat die
und eine neue sprache lernen
und neue welt kennen zu lernen und es
war eine sehr fröhliche unsere junge
zeit in dem sinne ich war wie neu
geboren als flüchtling in deutschland ja
das ist auch das perfekte schlusswort
noch einmal gratulation an alle und
gratulation an dich zu deinem demnächst
kommen wir den geburtstag wir haben so
sagt man nicht das ist ja das bringt
unglück in deutschland das bringt
unglück in deutschland also zwei tage
abwarten und dann alle bitte gratuliert
liebe leute danke dass er mitgemacht
habe beim großen ratespiel wir haben uns
sehr gefreut eure kommentare zu lesen
und ihr dürft auch jetzt wieder
kommentare schreiben
schreibt uns fragen und ideen für neue
videos und werdet ein mitglied von the
german das ist eigentlich das beste
geschenk was ihr janisch zum geburtstag
machen könnt denn damit unterstützt ihr
unsere arbeit und lernt mehr deutsch der
liebe grüße und bis nächste woche
[Musik]